this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
heather mills at the anchor desk sherry
swensgon weather nathan tonenbaum
starting us off this half hour because
of a car that was on fire now this was
over an hour ago so the freeway is
actually in better shape but we want to
let you know that there was a dangerous
situation there around the airport
connector on the 215 southern beltway
the fire ended up being on the connector
road so at 4 15 this morning just over
an hour ago here we had pictures live
video again more than an hour ago around
the 215 beltway car was on fire it has
been cleared out now so that is the good
news the airport connector and the 215
both moved along a great shape but while
we were sending hector mejia on his way
to that scene he found a rolled over car
near the terminal 1 parking garage this
is the picture that hector sent us just
a little while ago in fact hector is
live around the airport property because
not only of this picture but also
because of that car fire so hector a lot
going on around the airport this morning
[Music]
a lot going on and on a friday one we
expect a lot of people to head to the
airport right now we have paradise right
behind us traffic is still light so the
scene that is closer to the terminal one
departures is not really tying up
traffic along paradise it is though
right in that immediate area and we have
video of that scene of the crash a car
flipped and it's on its top metro police
on the scene responding and reporting
this as an injury crash we also saw just
a few feet away metro police with one
person in custody we don't know if
that's related to the scene of the crash
but it was tying traffic just a bit for
those heading over to the terminal 1
departures we're talking about you know
vehicles uh taxis ubers lifts and also
the shuttles trying to reach that scene
and again no big impact to paradise but
if you're headed for the airport you
might want to give yourself some extra
minutes if you're going to fly out
because we have that scene there
blocking lanes of wayne newton boulevard
right at kitty hawk for those coming
from paradise that's latest out here
reporting live hector mejia live local
now